pues básicamente la gran crítica que se
hace en este momento joe biden y la
respuesta a tu pregunta está ahí es que
arabia saudita se constituye como un
pilar fundamental en este momento para
dos estrategias de eeuu en la región que
es la lucha contra el terrorismo por un
lado y por supuesto también tiene que
ver con el hecho de la lucha que se está
dando contra irán en este momento no una
lucha abierta de guerra sino por la
hegemonía en la región entre arabia
saudita irán entonces en ese sentido
muchos afirman que se están sacrificando
la justicia y que es más importante
la estrategia de eeuu en la región que
la la muerte pues de el periodista que
soy y lo que esto implica en materia de
libertad de expresión y de derechos
humanos para la prensa en el mundo
entonces qué posición debería tomar eeuu
emite en un reporte que culpa el
príncipe saudita pero siguen teniendo
vínculos con él donde quedan las
promesas hechas por el gobierno
estadounidense
básicamente ellos lo que intentaron
hacer fue como ponerle pañitos de agua
tibia al asunto publica en el informe
también libre y desclasificar en el
informe que era un informe de tres
páginas donde la conclusión del informe
es que básicamente nada se hace en
arabia saudita sin la aprobación de bin
salman crean una ley que se llama la
prohibición que yogi en honor al
periodista y quitan el visado de 76
personas implicadas con
persecuciones a gente por fuera
disidentes del régimen de arabia saudí y
por el otro lado pues la gran crítica
que se hace y precisamente de ahí se
deriva tu pregunta es y qué pasa con bin
salman que ha sido el clasifica está
logrado precisamente al final del
informe como el responsable dado que se
dice que el pool que dio la orden
entonces una posición bastante ambigua
que creo que no va a ser suficiente
sobre todo para las organizaciones de
derechos humanos y dado que biden
criticó tanto al gobierno de trump por
la posición que asumió frente a este
caso y frente precisamente al príncipe
bin salman esta va a ser una digamos
uno de los argumentos que van a tener
sus contradictores para seguir
presionando en este respecto pero dudo
de todas maneras que la posición vaya a
cambiar o vaya a moverse de ahí por la
importancia que representa a arabia
saudita en este momento para eeuu y la
cooperación que tiene con los estados
unidos
margarida muchas gracias por este
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en france24